foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I'm taking my Q from like the real
lady at the heart of this episode who is
uh super interested which we'll get into
yeah she's over the top
yeah
I kind of thought she was cool though I
was like I kind of feel like me and her
could hang out this is a good episode
Danny Rowling said if this is yeah
that's right the lady on the cover of
this episode the one that played uh the
mom yeah that was the same that was
Cody's mom from demon child yeah that's
right yeah I forgot about that I knew
I'd seen her before but I forgot it was
the iconic this is this is a good
episode I don't know if the case
actually happened but it's a good it's a
good story
yeah it's like this one sounds a little
far-fetched gonna not gonna lie but um I
mean they all sound a little bit
far-fetched to me but this one sounds uh
like pretty far-fetched the people that
were telling the story though
the the boyfriend or the husband he was
for he said professional reasons that he
had he's gonna [__] tell his story
from anonymity
and then the mom she is good at telling
the story she's real emotive you know
yeah that's one way of putting it yeah
it almost
you know
maybe it happened to her I don't know
and then the boy he kind of like a kind
of like a Chrissy High's knockoff yeah I
wrote that down because you said it
looks like Emo Christian yeah he had
like this hair yeah like I know that was
all the rage when this I don't know what
it wasn't actually because I think this
episode came out in 2012 and I think
that hairstyle was that really years out
of data at that point but it was just
kind of like this round yeah it's Shaggy
yeah it's not pretty unfortunate the the
the the boyfriend or the husband
speaking from anonymity
well maybe we'll get into it later based
on what he said
something happened he thought something
was happening may not have been what the
mom thought it was but we'll you know
I don't know I don't know we'll get into
this I always wonder about that because
didn't we do the episode that we did
last week I think which um was the the
attic one with the main guy and he was
like you know I'm gonna be in Shadow but
then like everybody else on the show was
just regular so you know it is well
right and I was like I kind of feel like
that was the same way with this and it's
like the woman is on there and it's like
he's like well I have to be in Shadow
I'm like yeah but that's your wife if
everybody knows who your wife is yeah
that's your stepson then obviously
they're gonna know that's you and
they're probably gonna recognize your
voice and [__] like that yeah the people
that you're hiding from would know that
that's you they'd be your wife it's just
kind of like I'll just show you it seems
kind of a pointless yeah it seems kind
of pointless I don't know but you know
it'd be like doing only fans with your
wife right doing hot wife and [__] BBC
hot wife and everything but you got wife
in a mask yeah everybody knows who your
wife is God damn
I mean I know some people don't want
their faces on camera like for other
reasons but you know what I mean or
people are like you know they are
uncomfortable with it and that's fine
but I'm just saying that I know you're
not Anonymous if everybody else on the
show is like showing their actual faces
this is everybody that knows you is
gonna everybody yeah you're trying to be
anonymous only to the people that know
you they don't know you it doesn't
matter that's what I mean yeah it's like
you're already Anonymous everybody who
doesn't know you so yeah man put this
mask on so none of my friends know it's
you
I mean
I don't know it's just like it's just
weird to me yeah but uh but yeah
so uh you also said that the real lady
like that her name is Kathy sheets by
the way is is her name uh she Bears a
pretty striking resemblance to Sigourney
Weaver yeah cuter though actually you
think I think she's cuter than Sigourney
Weaver
security wave is kind of tall long not
real cute if you ask me
yeah shoot this was she was like kind of
a slightly shorter yeah slightly dumpier
yeah I don't know if I'd say I don't
know yeah sure yeah like a shorter
Journey Weaver yeah yeah like I said
this show is this episode I think this
was season five yeah and I think this
was 2012. so this came out like 11 years
ago now which isn't that long ago but
still it's like kind of a long time so
we talked about this before because I
feel like season five they were
deliberately trying to make the [__]
more like cinematic so they were doing
it more and I noticed this like on one
of the other season five episodes we did
too they started doing flash forwards
because they I guess they wanted to get
into the good [__] quicker so it's like
they do like a cold open on this episode
where there's this real heightened like
you know exorcism because you know
there's going to be an exorcism at the
end of one called Angels and Demons you
know so and just like everyone's just
like by the neighbor Define their blah
blah blah with the cross and everything
and everybody's like super heightened
emotion and like screaming and crying
and everything and so they show it all
like that with all the flashing lights
and then they're like one year earlier
you know what I mean so yeah they're
trying to do it like a movie give you a
Flash Forward
they started doing that yeah yeah
um Danny Rolex said Sigourney looks like
she has a five inch [__] well you know
so garny's not cute she's a good looking
woman but she's not cute
she's too tall and thin to be cute she's
a striking woman
I always thought she was very striking
looking
she's cool not my type but she's cool
yeah but you're definitely not ugly you
know she's good looking yeah I don't I
don't think she's ugly I don't know
she's good but like I said I like I like
interesting looking people not
necessarily to me I thought she looked
Bland no not necessarily like
conventionally attractive I kind of like
people that are sort of interesting kind
of tall skinny bony kind of flat not
real flat but you know just not I like
curvy shorter curvy
murder Hornets had seen the Pope's
Exorcist at the movies yesterday if
Russell Crowe wasn't the lead actor it
would be another boring Possession movie
I give it five out of ten yeah there
really are a lot of possession movies
and I'm kind of not I'm more excited
about Renfield to be honest
I mean I heard the Pope's Exorcist was
okay but I've heard mixed things on the
x's on the Pope's Exorcist yeah again
these nests liked it yeah he thought he
liked it yeah
I don't know like I said possession
movies are not it's just kind of like
zombie movies it's like every now and
then you see a good one but there's so
many of them is that streaming already
what one the Russell Crowe one
um I don't know unless they released it
simultaneously if they did it's probably
it's probably like twenty dollars
because it'll be 20 for like the first
however many like well yeah you get 20
to get a Blu-ray
yeah or you can just wait till it's like
five bucks you know a couple a month or
so from now yeah
uh Ann also says the new Evil Dead
trailer looks badass yeah I do kind of
want to see that too it rebooted Evil
Dead
well I think it's a sequel and it's not
like a remake
but uh yes Santa does said that he's
gonna send us King in New York
oh nice yeah all right he liked a review
of the movie that we did oh I kind of
want to mention too like on the show
yesterday remember how I said that we
got the um the package from Celtic Angel
73 and we showed a lot of the stuff that
was in it like the Reagan um The
Exorcist uh Funko Pop and she sent us um
the shirts that we were wearing
yesterday the black Christmas one and
the pink one and like yeah Amazon uh
gift card for Pookie in Beijing I forgot
to mention that also in the Box she sent
us the entire series of Bates Motel
that's right we're watching it and we
are watching it right now I've been
watching I watched like a couple
episodes
yeah yeah so I so I feel bad because I
was like coming home it's like oh [__]
well I didn't have it with us because we
had started watching it so it was in the
bedroom like yeah you know what I mean
so far it's been a good series it's
we're still like maybe like we're in the
first season probably like five or so
episodes in it's getting kind of boring
to me I hope it gets a little bit more
it's not though like there was all kind
of crazy not really keeping my attention
but you know what I mean I'm gonna keep
myself a lot you miss a lot yeah it was
just like yeah you know he was wandering
it it was stuff I had to do and I was
like it's add his ADD ass like wondering
Jenny was liking it though yeah I got I
was really into it yeah
I have to say that at one episode I
watched last night
um was it a fan of that scene of that
little dog and getting run over I didn't
see it yikes yeah I was like as soon as
that as soon as that happened I was like
oh well that's enough for me for tonight
I think because it was like real
realistic looking and I'm just like yeah
no thanks
all right so let's talk about angels and
demons all right and this Sigourney
Weaver looking lady all right and her
trials and tribulations with
look like that anymore well the weird
thing about this is that the
um he's an okay looking kid like I think
it was I mean he had braces he's kind of
awkward looking he's like he's a teenage
boy you know what I mean and uh you know
he had kind of that haircut that a lot
of those boys had back then which you
know not super flattering but I will say
that the real kid looked better than the
actor that they had playing him because
the actor that they had play in him was
like that was that was some haircut they
had on Ikea and he was another one that
had like real big nostrils just like
that other one that they had remember
that other episode from season five was
like what was it all the big nostrils I
mean like not like I can not like I can
talk because I have big huge nostrils
too but I'm just saying I wasn't paying
attention people's nostrils I'm not
nostril fool
because you know I have big huge nozzles
also but it's just kind of like I don't
know why well I think the reason I
noticed it on the show is because it
they were flaring them like and they
were so there was these big two like
black holes oh I want to just mention
that uh before the show goes on even
more just let you guys know uh some [__]
is happening behind the scenes and some
of the some of the tight Friends of the
show I pierce Jen's nipples yeah both
for the first time over the weekend over
the weekend yeah [__] with like 450 I
think it was a 14 gauge needle and I had
all the gear to do it and [__] it
came out good they came out real good
yeah they look really nice show them to
a friend of mine that uh um got it owns
Quinn Studios is he's a pornographer him
and his wife and he used to be an animal
pornographer
and uh he he was uh he pierced
professionally for years I showed him
the photos he's like oh yeah that's good
it's depth is good they're straight goes
yeah a good deal yeah you did a good job
and yeah that [__] was [__] I had
I've been putting needles through myself
for a long time
going through a leg and going through a
nipple [__] tutor man that [__]
crunched and cracked and popped going
through that thing I was I was Disturbed
but I couldn't stop man I just had to
and then once one was done imagine how I
felt yeah
wow it's gonna be soft as butter then
the needle would just go into it no it
took a lot of pressure I was like I was
thinking to myself I didn't say at the
gym that first when I was going what the
[__] man am I am I hitting bone how is
that possible like I don't have any
bones yeah how is that [__] possible
it's not that I know of anyway so she
got two bars in there now they look good
just like little beads little yeah
but holy [__] wow that hurt like a
[__] well the thing about it was
that I mean I have a really high pain
tolerance okay you know like I've had
all kind of like fashion it's like
usually doesn't bother me I expected it
to hurt
um I didn't expect it to hurt that much
though yeah
actually when you were doing the first
one uh I had to lay down because I
started to black out that's how much it
hurt yeah I can understand I started to
blackout don't try that on your own
people unless you have some experience
so we this is the second one we had like
I had to lay back and yeah and because I
was saying certain things didn't go
smoothly like I had to do one twice
because I accidentally misplaced the
wrong size needle it wasn't quite the
same diameter as the as as the as the
bar that had to go in there and the bar
couldn't follow it I was like [__] and
she was [__] freaking out it was the
second one and I wasn't thinking I just
grabbed the other needle and pulled it
through it says it was the wrong size I
got to get the bigger one I should have
just turned out bigger I should have
just took the bigger one and [__] put
it to the back of the small one and
pushed that through the hole again and
then it would have corrected itself
but I was kind of uh a little bit
wigging out you know it wasn't bleeding
but I knew it hurt a lot you know so oh
it did and um well he did one and then I
was just kind of like maybe I should
just leave it with one I don't want to
be crooked and everything because I was
like man that hurt like way more than I
was expecting like I think it was like
the pain was bad but I think the thing
that bothered me the most was like the
the blacking out like I almost blacked
out like my vision Whip and I was like
I'm blacking out I'm blacking out black
out I was like please stop
um you know what I mean so
so that kind of like Disturbed me so I
didn't really want to go through that
again but I was like well I don't really
want to be crooked either but I was like
you need to like let me chill out for
yeah for a few hours yeah like and I
said and also I'm I need to be a little
bit drunk yeah so I had to like I had to
yeah I had to drink some before we did
the second one
so uh yeah don't
it's not like go you know I've had a lot
of experience sucking going through meat
and flesh and
uh because I get myself injections a lot
and then uh experience with [__]
vivisection and and
um
dissection in high school their biology
classes and being well yeah Food Service
second butcher animals and [__] and
and uh so I I had some background in
doing [__] like this I just didn't
realize how tough a [__] nipple was
it was like going through
well like you said yeah well they
they're stretching and popping and
cracking and I'm going like damn they
have to be like that because babies like
yeah nurse off them I thought I was
gonna go through there like like butter
like just like it was going through fat
but no and it was a big I I admit before
you even did it like when you showed me
the needle it was doing I'm like oh [__]
what the [__] did I even yeah why why
did we have this idea yeah now see Danny
rolling said Jenny should Pierce Tom's
areola see that's what I said I said now
it's your turn I would have done and he
was like [__] no and I would have done
that figures I would have done had it
been an easy procedure once I felt how
much pressure it takes to go through
that material hell no I wouldn't do that
I wouldn't have any problem anywhere
else but not on a nipple that shit's
[__] too tough
after I did that procedure I laid him to
bed going to sleep started thinking
about it again and I'm going oh damn I
can't believe I did that [__] [__]
but that came out good like I said how
do you think I feel yeah I was on the
receiving head yeah
murder Hornet said I had my navel
piercing back in the mid 90s I can still
put a ring through it I said I sent
I said murderhearted some pictures of
him well yeah and he only just told me
that yeah and I was like who else are
you sending pictures of my boobs a
couple people a couple people he's not
gonna tell me who well Quinn was one and
then a couple more just but they're
they're friends they're friends
oh Jan well I know that I don't care
have you seen my boobs yeah so soap
soaps on yeah she goes yeah well yeah
yeah you told me so you know just people
like that I mean I'm not that boss
there's people I just I I mean it's just
because sometimes I wish sometimes you
would I wish you just like asked me
before you do it I probably okay I
should probably say yes oh I know you
would because I'm not that I'm not that
shy about that it's not like it's got
your face they're like medical photos
anyways you know there's no face yeah
they're just boobs yeah
they're called breasts and everyone yeah
that was from The Young Ones by the way
um all right so now that we're done
talking about that let's talk about
angels and demons
Danny rolling said you forgot to send a
photo to moderator David June Tom
[Laughter]
thank you so you're probably not yeah I
got the [__] I got the I got the only
fans pretty uh uh just opened it up I
gotta search it yeah there's nothing on
there
laughs
Jazz laughing you're gonna do only fans
I said yeah yeah we'll see we'll see how
it goes you know you're [__] [__]
with her mostly but no there's no
telling what could happen I mean you set
it up so obviously yeah so obviously you
want to get into that
well yeah it doesn't have to be porn you
can put anything on there yeah I know
Zach says Jenny should give Tom a Prince
Albert because that's yeah that's
another one that would [__] hurt
that's what I was thinking another one
never hurt I was like yeah like if if I
asked you to do that would you do it no
no now that I saw a [__] course what
it's like going through that strange
material [__] no that's strange material
yeah I mean I got no problem sticking it
through through legs and [__] like that
for just well that's different I mean
going through anything that's like
because he gives me injections all the
time too and it's like it's nothing but
it's nothing but you know anything going
through stretchy materials and
cartilages and [__] like that no
I could do it I mean I knew it was gonna
be where like I pierced my own ears like
years ago yeah and they said that's
still they're still in there too even
though you hardly ever wear earrings but
yeah I don't think I'd go through a
tongue or anything I'm not going through
any kind of damn organ
yeah I know I wouldn't want my tongue
pierced anyway well to be honest that
just seems like a pain in the ass like I
feel like I know that some people like
having them and it's like you know
that's up to them but I would not get
that it just seemed like a little stud
here you know what I mean yeah like that
kind of [__] yeah that'd be easy or I
like the ones there's a little bar that
just goes through like the upper
shoulder part right so that because
that's real soft yeah that's just skin
it's just skin There's real soft and you
know you don't really need a big gauge
needle to go through it you know you
could do probably a 20 gauge 25 gauge
you go through that you know it would
just slip through you wouldn't even feel
it
but uh Tammy said Tom's gonna print up a
t-shirt with a picture of Jen's boobs on
it yeah that would be funny you just put
like my boobs where your boobs out yeah
like
didn't they used to have that those
shirts back in the 70s that were like
they're they were for dudes but then
they had like a woman's boobs like with
a bra on them or something yeah am I
just I remember seeing that yeah like a
long time like in the 80s maybe yeah it
was black and white
uh it's a black and white like a Xerox
photograph of [__] boobs and it was
on the shirt
Danny Rowling said once they heal you
should get a chain piercing that
connects your ear piercings to your
nipple piercings and make a makeshift
chain to your wallet
you just hang [__] on it but I was gonna
think I'm drying out my laundry you know
what I was gonna do is once once they're
all healed up if she gets bored with
them we'll put some like one inch rings
with a captured ball in there you need a
little tool yeah we got like a kit like
it came with a bunch of different ones
but it didn't come with the
I didn't didn't come with the tool that
you need to close it and keep everything
all around
because you have to bend it and you slip
it through and there I'm not sure it's
quite the right size it has to be
similar to the the size of the two of
the piercing I went through there so
probably about an inch inch and a half
like that would do it and you bend it
you slip it through there like that and
then you bend it back close you got to
put the ball in there and then there's a
tool that you use to make everything
round again and then you put the ball in
place it's got two dimples on it and it
takes a lot of practice and if it's a
little ball it's
slipping around like the one that we
have it's I couldn't get back in even
when it wasn't in a person
so I didn't want to [__] with that it's
too hard you know what's hilarious to me
like before and I promise we'll get back
to the talking about yeah but um I guess
you know how we get
um the thing that I found hilarious was
that the kit that you bought I was like
it comes with they have a specific clamp
that is specifically for that piercing
like yeah that you like pull it out and
has like little rings so you can pull it
out and like you know and it's you can
uh adjust it yeah and I was like the
first thing I thought of was like
somewhere in the world there's a factory
that makes that very specific tool I
wonder how many of them they make
there's another one grabs your nostrils
it's got a hole to do a septum pierced
septum piercing yeah which that's gotta
[__] kill
I'm sure that probably hurts like like
yeah like up here doesn't hurt but it's
like um yeah but yeah down here would
probably I'm not doing any of that [__]
going through cartilage or anything any
soft [__] flexible materials well I'm
not really lining up to do it again and
I've known and I'd known had I known
what that what that material was was
like in there I would have done it
you know it's done I got it done and it
came out good but I you know had I known
what that felt like what had I known
what I felt like push through it how
much pressure that needed I would have
[__] went nope I could do that I mean
it was very counterintuitive to me it
hurt oh yesterday but today it's like
not I got some um what do you call it
antibiotic cream with a painkiller in it
yeah there's no sign of infection
everything was yeah it looks totally
fine everybody was going to look totally
fine
but uh but yeah so let's go ahead and
get back to it though got that one out
of the way okay we got more people in
there now yeah all right now now that
we're talking about now what's up but uh
yeah I'm trying to think of like a segue
from going for nipple piercing into the
ghost but I deal with ghosts man I can't
really deal with demons demons and
angels and [__] yeah I felt like I was
dealing with demons that's for sure holy
[__] have an out-of-body experience I
don't think that's the worst pain I've
ever felt but it was up there it was
five out of ten it was no I said six six
maybe seven all right
um but it was up there probably in the
top five yeah since it had to be in the
top five like the worst pain I've ever
experienced because uh yeah it sucked a
lot pretty rough it sucked a lot but
yeah never again
yeah well and piercing nipples again
laughs
yeah I don't know how much that would
have cost that's probably a 200 job yeah
I don't know how much that how much they
charge it's like I said I I did my own
ears but I never got any other ones done
professionally
um all right so as I said they started
this one with a Flash Forward because
they're trying to make it more like a
movies there's like a crazy like
over-the-top exorcism where everyone's
waving crosses around and whatnot
everyone's crying and screaming and why
not so they do that for a few seconds
and then they're like one year earlier
so this story takes place in I guess
like the Autumn of 2010 in a place
called Arnold Maryland which they said
was right outside of Annapolis I'm not
from Maryland so I don't really know my
mom is but uh yeah
So This Woman's name is Kathy sheets I'm
presuming that's her real name because
her real face was on there and like we
said she kind of looked like Sigourney
Weaver
so she has a 15 year old son who is 15
at the time uh his name is Michael
um and she has been a single mom you
know pretty much all of her kids life I
guess
however in Fall of 2010 she's moving in
with her boyfriend whose name is Brian
Davis like I said I don't know if that's
his real name because he just uh
came up in Shadow you know what I mean
he was just there in Shadow so that
might not be his real name
so Brian is has just finalized his
divorce from his uh previous wife and
he's kind of nervous about doing this
new thing but they're moving in together
in bloody blah
now here's okay so we backed this up
because they were like okay well Brian
was staying in the when they move into
this new house I think it was she said
it was a townhouse but I thought like
the house they showed on there wasn't
really a townhouse but whatever but I
guess in Maryland like a lot of the
houses are townhouses
so he there was a spare bedroom in the
basement and they said that Brian was
sleeping in the basement I said why is
he sleeping in the basement it's like
they're to get I mean their boyfriend
girlfriend right like so why is he
sleeping down in the basement and she's
a dizzy snore
I don't know and then I was like well
why wait why is he in the basement and
then we like backed it up and I guess
they didn't say or I totally missed it
so because I put Brian's in the basement
for some reason I don't know why he's
sleeping either
so he got in trouble I guess so he's out
of the basement and he said that he
heard somebody like walking behind him
when he was walking down there he said
it was very very clear like very much
sounded like somebody's walking behind
him and then when he was down in the
basement like he could hear the
footsteps like kind of walking around
the room even though obviously he
couldn't see anybody yeah he said he
didn't know if it was maybe the boards
Heating and Cooling or what but he said
he definitely
heard something that sounded like
footsteps going going around yeah so
even though he he's being shot in Shadow
there's something kind of credible about
his testimony especially later on when
like uh they're confronted confronting
the [__] demon or Spirit or whatever
it is he says some things that kind of
make me think that that he's telling the
truth
because it wasn't very fantastic what he
said but we'll get into that middle yeah
I remember what he said
I might have written it down but maybe
not so remember what he said yeah
but um so yeah so he tries to kind of
like write it off uh you know yeah like
maybe it's the ventilation system or
maybe it's just the floors creaking or
bloody blast so he doesn't really
mention it to his girlfriend
now for a while Brian is staying in the
old house like I guess while they're you
know getting everything moved around or
whatever
so Michael the Son and the mom Kathy are
in the new house now one of the first
things that happens is Michael is in his
room and he's on he's working on his
laptop like doing homework or whatever
and he sees something like it looks like
something moving and I think it was like
it was kind of dark on the TV so I
couldn't really see what it was but I
think it was like some kind of
reflection of maybe something behind him
and it was like reflected in the laptop
screen that's kind of what it looked
like to me
so he sees something he's like what the
[__] and he like looks behind and
there's nobody there but he said the
real kid said it felt like a spider a
spider crawled up his back but there was
like nothing there so he kind of like
felt a presence I guess
so he goes to tell his mom but uh
apparently it's three in the morning and
she's like not having it which you know
I don't I don't blame her gonna be
waking me up at three in the morning
telling me about some [__] ghost in
your room man up deal with it so uh he
does feel like something is like
watching him and touching him though
like I guess he said that's what it felt
like like something came over and
touched him
so then I don't know if there's that
same night or maybe like the next night
so Kathy's bed starts shaking like
Exorcist Style
now the first thing she thought was
maybe it's an earthquake or maybe
something heavy like fell down in the
house and like shook the bed or
something
yeah she just saying hey you know shook
the bed but when they show it and then
they show her reaction and her talking
about it
I had some weird [__] happen to me like
this at Mammoth you know
first night I was there it scared her
she said something was shaking the bed
she said you know and that would that
would that kind of [__] really freaks
you out didn't shake my bed but it was
moving things around I could hear it and
it picked up the damn receiver the
telephone [__] dropped it
that was a weird [__] man and you and
you're like that didn't happen that did
not just happen you're just going to
denial you know well that's kind of what
these two were doing yeah they were she
was just kind of like well maybe it was
an earthquake no way you're scared and
shitless you go that did not happen you
try to shut that [__] out but hell yeah
it happened
because it keeps on doing it
Julianne said they said he stayed in the
basement to let the kid get used to them
living together okay Steve that's what I
mean I thought they said something about
it but then we backed it up and I
couldn't find where he said it so
because I was like there was got to be a
reason I'm like that's kind of weird but
okay so thank you for saying that
because
we did back it up but I had for some
reason I didn't like see that
so uh so yeah
no earthquake knows but she's just like
okay well I'm gonna try and not like pay
attention to that or whatever however
she does go to a friend of hers named
Bonnie who also happens to be a psychic
um and she goes there to kind of ask I
don't think she goes initially to ask
her about the the ghosty situation but
she does ask like about her and Brian
and then so Bonnie busts out the tarot
cards and then of course this is season
five it's 2012 when this came out it's
like everybody knows what the [__] tarot
cards are it's just like everybody knows
what EVPs are but they feel the need to
like explain it every single time and I
don't really understand why they have to
do that but so um yeah so she brings out
the tarot cards and uh she's basically
like
well you know your relationship has a
good potential but you know there are no
guarantees I'm like you know any [__]
tarot cards to tell you that yes you're
just real psychic there aren't you but
yeah Danny's saying that I could I could
Rock a damn eyebrow piercing now that
actually uh Danny I wouldn't get any
piercings on my face because I get into
fights now so you don't want anything
that would
gets [__] up if you get punched maybe
I could do ears or something like that
or up around in body parts but nothing
on my face I wouldn't do it
yeah probably not a great idea no
because someone will nothing someone
ripped out that yeah yeah you know any
kind of now I'm kind of like paranoid
about like any weak spots on my face
yeah I don't blame you
um okay
so
I guess like a few days later
she goes back down to the basement and
the light doesn't work which you know
that's not necessarily paranormal or
whatever but she goes over there to like
open the curtains so she can see what
she's doing
and then she turns around and sees just
like a dark figure she didn't really
describe it all that much did she they
just kind of had it I mean on there they
have kind of like your standard demon
looking like a scary looking dude in a
hood like she was just saying it was
just like a dark shadowy humanoid figure
yeah probably just an outline it's
probably what she's talking about she
didn't give any details yeah so this
freaks her out understandably
and um she tells Brian but he just
doesn't believe her and doesn't tell her
about but he heard a bunch of stuff down
there in the basement too but he's just
like oh I don't know where you're
talking about you know what I mean I'm
like he's he comes across at least the
actor like came across as like a little
bit douchey
on this one the real guy not so much but
you know
so then it seemed like the next day
she's sitting in the living room or
whatever and she said out of the corner
of her eye she saw something she said it
was fast and white like out of the
corner variety turns out guess what she
saw a demon now she sees a big ass Angel
yeah big big angel with its wings spread
out
like a guardian angel she said that she
thought she was dead that she's like
well it's not the only time you're
supposed to see that [__] that's when
you die she said she saw it for about
five seconds and it was very clear so
there's there's the angel so now we have
Angel and Demon so we've got two sides
of the [__] going here now
so she goes back to her friend Bonnie
who is the psychic and Bonnie says well
this is probably your spirit guide
thingy uh either trying to help you or
trying to warn you about something
so at this point Kathy's like you know
what um I'm I I really don't have time
for this nonsense right now so I'm just
kind of ignore this [__] until it all
blows it for I guess
so June of 2011 Brian's divorce is
finally final finally final
so Kathy and Brian decide to get married
so they get married
now she's in the kitchen one night
chopping vegetables for a romantic
dinner because Michael's out at a
friend's house so you know they got some
alone time Bow Chicka Wow so there's
that now while she's cutting up the
vegetables she said her um hand goes
numb and then she looks at her hands and
they're like blue
and then her the back of her head went
numb too she said
she thought she was having a stroke
which is yeah what you would think
probably
so she calls 9-1-1 as you would so they
actually the ambulance comes and they
take her to the hospital
now when she gets to the hospital uh
they find that her blood pressure is
what they say 200 over 100 which is it's
pretty high yeah that's pretty high
um and they basically say well we can't
she seems okay now but it's like you
know that
that high of a blood pressure or spiking
that much like is kind of consistent
with like a stroke or maybe like a
cardiac arrest or something but she
didn't really have any of that but they
do keep her overnight
um so they're not really sure what's
wrong with her so basically they're just
like their go-to in this session is like
well maybe it was a panic attack you
know maybe it was like stress induced so
okay because there didn't really seem to
be any lingering effects or whatever so
Kathy goes home the next morning
then there's a scene where she's talking
to an old friend on the phone like about
this whole situation
and then while she's talking on the
phone like from behind like the cameras
like it's all wavy and [__] like it's
like there's somebody back there and
then something's behind her and like her
hair like it was like that like some
blue on it and then that scary dude like
the demon guy is like right behind her
and she like turns around and [__]
screams and all that kind of [__]
what do you think I was gonna say did
she see a [__] shot because fast and wait
maybe that's it
blue
[Laughter]
on that's what it is
yeah maybe she's she got only fans too
maybe that could be our only fans angle
we'll do like a whole paranormal like
[Laughter]
it acts like the only thing that's is
real that's not just a story yeah I
gotta we got only fans I think it's just
called Tom and Jen
I think it's what it's called right now
it's Gotta it's just gotta it's just got
a picture of us there's nothing on it
yeah there's nothing nothing on it no no
but he just shared because I thought he
was kidding too but then he was like
twice that went up yeah
Zach's like duh you know
I want to see that yeah Zach maybe it'll
just be me just be me Zach doing solos
Joi instructions for you gays
together you got to send me money
laughs I'll see if you start out here
and it's like maybe you make a lot of
money maybe I'll get it then you get
involved yeah you come and give me your
head yeah
like I said I want to see if there's any
money in it first
before you probably make more at it than
I would
probably true yeah probably true yeah I
mean you know I don't I don't mean that
in any like usually girls make more
money no matter what they look like so
but the only dudes that are making money
they're uh it's either very much uh man
on man action that's the orientation you
know what I mean yeah it's gay or it's
dudes that are going around doing
collaborations with other only fans
chicks you know what I mean so he's he's
basically just being a porn star yeah
and on his on his channel he's got a
bunch of different
performers he's performed with
on his channel they've just kind of
split the money or he probably pays them
yeah for the to be in the scene with him
right
okay so this is uh I guess like the
second time she's seen the demon right
so now soon after this she's picking up
Michael from school so she's like
sitting in the car like in front of the
school or whatever and she said this is
kind of like a funny scene it would
probably be scary if it really happened
to you but it was like just funny the
way they shot it but um I guess there's
like she said it felt like an invisible
thing like pushing on her head like it
was gonna snap her neck so it's like
pushing her head like into this real
like unnatural position and she can't
talk and she can't breathe and
everything like that so she's all like
wow like in the front seat of the car
and like trying to pray and like I said
it was pretty funny like that like
Cody's mom like from the demon child
episode she was uh she was having some
problems with her with her neck you know
so she's trying to pray uh but can't
like I said so Michael runs to the cards
like Mom what the hell you know what I
mean like why is your head all [__] up
like it's all in a weird position and
everything so uh Michael starts praying
because I guess Mom can't and uh at this
point he tells her that he has also been
experiencing [__] in the house and they
show at this point I guess this is kind
of like a flashback but he said that he
was in his room one night and this kind
of reminded me of like some [__] that
happened
at Mammoth like the the first thing that
happened with the with the bag and the
socks because he's like sitting in his
room and he said he was on the laptop
and his backpack was on the bed and he
said something like it looked like an
invisible something was like pulling on
the straps of the backpack like that
yeah and then he said it just like
picked up and like threw itself across
the room yeah so Poltergeist phenomenal
it's nice yeah yeah yeah
he was probably the right age
15 he was when this happened
um so once the kid like told her that
like Kathy said she got really upset
because she you know she didn't know
this was happening to him too and she's
like I felt like a failure because I
wasn't protecting him and blah blah
um and at this point they're trying to
like now her and Michael are both
talking to Brian about this and uh he
basically says it's all in your head and
I'm like that's nice uh you know so I
put it right yeah Brian thinks it's all
in her head and it's being a real douche
about it that's that's kind of uh yeah
he was being a
a real man on this one where he was just
like that you're just a woman you sure
you're not like imagining all this stuff
she's like hey my son sees the [__] too
you know what I mean yeah it was pretty
special
so that same night uh they all sleep in
the same room
and Michael suddenly sits up
in bed and starts doing like a demonie
kind of voice
but what he and what he was saying was
an argument that Kathy and Brian had had
earlier like he repeated the argument
like word for word even though
apparently Michael had not been home
when they had this conversation like
he'd been at school or at a friend's
house or something so they were kind of
weirded out because they're like holy
[__] he's just up there sitting up in
bed like talking to this creepy voice
and he's saying exactly what they said
and uh I think at that point like Brian
was kind of on board but he was just
like okay maybe something weird is going
on and everybody's like duh you know
what I mean
no no I thought you were gonna say so
because you kind of went like that like
you were gonna say something yeah
I can't ever tell so yeah so Brian
finally admits oh yeah well maybe maybe
might be some possession Jazz going on
here so then they call this Paranormal
Investigator guy named uh Hiram and I
can't I went to write down his last name
but they were going too fast and I was
like well nevermind your name is Hiram
yeah hiring something I don't remember
what his last name was
um and I think they said it used to be
like he was like a dis I don't think
they said he was CIA but maybe he was
like intelligence or something like that
I don't remember what they said
but uh yeah he's a Paranormal
Investigator now
so he brings like ebps that [__]
Spirit Box he brings all that [__]
because I mean I I sort of puts more ice
in that okay
that Spirit Box thing that is that is
such crap by the way how much do they
charge for those nowadays I have to like
go on Amazon because I'm always well I'm
always kind of curious because I'm like
well
it's just it's essentially just a thing
that goes through radio frequencies
right that's all it is and but if you
call it like a specialized like
paranormal investigation tool then you
can probably like charge a lot more
money for it but that's literally all it
does it just goes through radio
frequencies and it's like just counts on
you to like pick out so I'm just like oh
my God it sounded like it was answering
my questions or whatever so yeah
audio paradolia
so yeah so he brings all the stuff now
he does all these EVPs and then he
brings like Kathy and Brian and them
like back to the office and he plays all
these EVPs back for them and they said
that all the EVP they were like look he
did like all of these tapes of EVPs and
they were just like stuffed with demon
voices like all over the [__] and they
said you couldn't like tell what they
were saying it just sounded like like it
sounded like garbled like a [__] I
don't know like a like 80s black metal
record or something but I guess like it
what they weren't really saying anything
right they just said it was all garbled
but there was like a whole bunch of
voices
poured a little bit of
a lock up on the top of that so it's
probably
e yeah okay
just only a little though just floating
around it's only little it's just
floating on the top
it'll mix it yeah so demon garbled demon
voices all over the [__]
so again Brian hears this and he's like
okay yeah I guess we do God demons
and so Hiram tells them your house is I
believe the wording he used was the
mother of all portals there's no you
can't just have one demon or two It's
gotta be a whole [__] way station
situation mother of all portals the
mother of all portals that's what he
said
so yeah so all the tapes he had like
that he took in there just like all over
the [__] had demon voices
um and at this point Hiram uh kind of
leaves the story because he's like well
I've done all I can do recording all
these Epps this is beyond my pay grade
so bye good luck with that you know what
I mean uh pretty much
now uh at this point too I think Kathy
like wakes up in the middle of the night
and she sees like this Mist she didn't
really explain it but the way that they
had it on the reenactment it kind of
looked like it was moving intelligently
Maybe
kinda and then um she sees like these
weird like flashing lights like outside
of the hall and then the fire alarm goes
off but there's not or the smoke alarm
but there's not any fire like they can't
find any finer fire so they assume
that's paranormal also
so Kathy at this point decides she's
gonna go to the church for help
so she goes to the priest
and then we were kind of laughing
because at first it seemed like the
priest was just gonna blow her off like
why don't you call god with that [__]
okay it's like I got [__] to do you know
because that's kind of what it sounded
like he was saying at first it's like
well you have God on your side so why
don't you call someone go call someone
who cares it was kind of like that it
was kind of amazing
[Laughter]
yeah I'm busy yeah
well it's like yeah why do we even need
you for anyway I mean if that's the
whole thing but um he does actually he
did actually like come out to their
house so he so he wasn't just blowing
him off but I just thought that was
really funny
uh so he comes in the house and
apparently feels like real oppressive
like bad energy or whatever
especially in the basement uh and they
said that his while he was doing the
blessing or whatever like his hands were
shaking and he was like scared and then
he's like uh he does the blessing and
he's like okay y'all are good uh just
pray and I'm out of here that's like
what the priests do in this situation
there's like yep we're done bye what you
doing she's calling you yeah hi she's
trying to jump up on the chair
so that night after the priest leaves uh
the family is very hopeful obviously
that the priest actually like kicked the
demons out their house
but Kathy this was not clear she said
that she woke up from a horrible dream
but then she was like it wasn't a dream
though so I was like well which is it
what are you talking about she said that
she woke up and she saw she just called
it a thing on the other side of the bed
so I'm assuming this is like the Demonic
figure that she's been seeing previously
she said it was three feet away and it
was looking right at her
um and she
she said she grabbed a crucifix and the
holy water which she keeps right there
for such purposes
um and then I put in my notes I would
put the real chick is really into this
I threw holy water all over my house and
she was like she's starting to get like
amped up like as the story is going on
but like you said she's a good
Storyteller though but it's like I'm not
real sure she's not like super
believable but she's she tells a good
story though
so the first thing in the morning uh she
calls the priest and was like what's the
deal like um the shit's still here and
it's getting worse than ever and she's
like I woke up this morning and I heard
it chanting
they didn't put that on the reenactment
but she said that that she heard it
chanting like when she woke up in the
morning uh and the priest basically says
yeah you probably um need to get the
[__] out the house
so they all Pile in the car and for
whatever reason Kathy says to the the
husband and the son no talking no one is
no one talks in this car so she's like
they just drove to a motel or something
like that just in complete silence for
whatever reason
so they stay in a motel one night
and then they come back the next day and
Kathy has decided that even though she
is just a regular ass person who looks
like Sigourney Weaver she is going to
um you know fight the aliens or fight
the demons rather like you know what I
mean well you know that's been maybe
that's where she was taking inspiration
from
get away from her you [__] but uh yes
that's what I was thinking while I was
watching this episode I just think
random [__] like that so um yeah so I
wrote in my notes I was like Kathy gonna
fight the [__] on her own gonna become a
Demon Slayer that's what I wrote on here
so yeah she's uh she's dropping her nuts
and she's gonna get rid of Demons by
herself because no one can help her I
guess and she's gonna close the portal
now I cannot convey to you I mean
because some of you obviously watched
this episode like after I announced
which one we were doing it's hard for me
to convey to you how super dramatic but
also how super entertaining this lady is
because as this story goes on she's just
like she's almost crying I can't explain
it it's like it's but it's super funny
though it's like it's I don't know it's
like it's hard to explain Jenny thinks
it made her less credible
more credible she
she made it you know she might have just
really [__] was affected by it she
believed it
now
her husband
he said during one of these episodes and
I think we might have passed it already
that they were yelling into the darkness
and he could
he didn't see anything but he could
sense there was something moving in
there isn't that what he said
or something like he could censor
something he didn't see anything but he
he could sense that something was wrong
yeah he did say something like that yeah
he said there was some kind of
disturbance happening back there but but
she was seeing more than he was seeing
evidently
yeah well she was seeing all kind of
crazy yeah she was seeing all kinds of
demons and angels he couldn't see
anything but he he uh he could sense
that there was a disturbance happening
yeah I think the only thing he's looking
the only thing he really experienced I
think was the footsteps at the beginning
and then he did hear the d The Demon
ebps and like the kid when the weird
demon voice like saying the argument
from earlier he did hear that I thought
he was pretty credible because he didn't
make any
wild claims really
he just said he heard footsteps and he
could sense there was a disturbance
strong and was imagining war that was
really hap than what was really
happening the disturbances might have
not have been all that impressive but
they felt impressive so so
I do kind of feel like there's a certain
kind of person that is more fantasy
prone yeah and a lot of times because
I'm not real fantasy prone
so I kind of feel like that certain
times when people when weird things
happen
certain types of people will really
conflate that and then usually like you
know after like the longer it goes on
like after it happens they'll keep like
adding more details and it'll just get
bigger and bigger in their head yeah and
they'll just keep like telling the story
until it gets like super outlandish even
though if you actually saw the actual
thing happen it was like some little wet
fart of a nothing well James actually
seen phenomena she saw them
damn remote just jump up off the table
and get thrown and it way it landed in
what way it sounded when it hit the
ground was sounded wrong and
doorbells ringing in the night nobody
there that type of stuff
but you weren't Real Fantasy proud you
saw it for what it was
you know maybe a person who is more
amped up more fantasy prone would have
said yeah
the the remote jumped off the table and
landed on the ground
but I saw what had it a demon had it
yeah they might have like thought and
had some [__] and I absolutely did not
do that yeah and in fact the weird thing
about it is that it was weird like when
it happened because it was like
startling but one it wasn't scary
necessarily it was almost kind of like
mundane if that makes any sense when you
see it happen you're like oh okay it
happens
yeah that's kind of like what I was like
huh yeah I was just kind of like that
because well for a second like I thought
you know the remote thing that was kind
of like the first thing that I saw and
then I was just kind of like
for a second I was like wait did that
did that just do what I thought it did
and then I looked over at Dimitri and
Jen because they were sitting right
there and they were looking at me and
they were like did not just do with it
and I was like okay so I was like check
I was looking for outside validation I
thought the first thing I thought was
like maybe I kicked the table
I was like I knew I didn't kick the
table but I was like maybe I kicked the
table and it flew off but I didn't kick
the table but that was like the first
thing I thought of yeah but then a stack
of coins appeared yeah but the weird
thing about it is that when it happens
it's almost kind of like oh okay yeah
like it's not there's not flashing
lights and sound effects and like you
know like in a movie it's just kind of
like oh the remote control just went
phew and just like flew off the table
that's like all that happened you know
what I mean like yeah that's freaky but
without as freaky as you think it is
yeah it's not as freaky as it would be
like in a movie there's not like a jump
scare like a musical sting or anything
like that it was just kind of like oh
okay that was strange
but yeah but this chick is like super
dramatic so she's so she's going in
there and she's gonna kick some Demon
butt right so she's calling on
she's calling on the Angel Warriors
that was I had to rate that down because
I thought that was really funny so so
I'm guessing that she's calling on the
warrior the angel that she saw earlier
Michael yeah
and going around uh rebuking and whatnot
and uh she's just like sitting there
she's just getting so like more and more
into thank you God for saving my life
and all this other kind of stuff and I'm
just like oh man she is really laying it
on thick but it was like not in an
annoying way though she did it like in
an entertaining kind of way like I said
I kind of want to hang out with her is
that weird is that weird to say like
normally people that go on and on like
this they would just like annoy the [__]
out of me but she wasn't annoying she
was just like really entertaining but
yeah she was just like going around
she's like I am never gonna be without
my crucifix ever again and all this
other kind of stuff and she's like and I
heard the Bible next to the band I heard
the angel saying like save her help her
you know she was getting like all into
it and she was so into it it was just
like so so funny what was that oh we
started with a thing I was like
um but she said while she was you know
rebuking the demons or whatever
that she actually did see the angel
again did she like she said it was the
same one I guess that she saw before
okay with the big wings and everything
like that you know just your standard
issues it's just a good the good job
like from from you know Central Casting
yeah and um she's like way over the top
but apparently this works the angel uh
she said that she felt the angel grip
her hand she's not not like hard like an
[__] or anything like that but just
like firm I got you yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean I'm gonna help you I
was like where the [__] have you been
this whole time like the Demon's been
like had to get permission [__] with
my neck and all this [__] and you just
did nothing you just stood there and did
nothing angel had to get permission
[Laughter]
all right you got that there it is yeah
and then God's up there being like nah
that person's a dick just just let the
demon torment them a little longer I
like to watch maybe that's what it was I
don't really know but yeah but I did
actually write down what the [__] where
the [__] was this Angel the whole time
yeah because it didn't show up until the
end of the show
like to help her it was like yeah we got
you now like I got permission I guess so
I can come in here and kick all the
demons out I don't know I guess it was
just the one demon so it should have
just been Angel and Demon
no I guess it was more than one demon
she just saw one but there was lots like
lots yeah but there was really technical
as if the demon could not impersonate 20
demons
yeah didn't anybody see The Exorcist
come on that was like pretty much the
whole there's only one
that was pretty much the whole [__]
premise of that [__] was that it was
like impersonating a bunch of different
ones
um but apparently her and the angels her
and her angel homies uh drove all the
demons out so however many there were
and uh so yeah she says now I I still
sleep in my crucifix in my holy water
and she has angels with her all the time
now so
okay you hear that demons like you
better not mess with Kathy because she's
got all the angels on her side and
they're gonna whip your ass I guess so
uh yeah that was that was about the end
of that Angels helped her kick the
demons out the end but they did have
like a super high like I said they that
was the thing that they did the The
Flash Forward like the super over the
top exorcism you know yeah it's a good
episode yeah and uh this season kind has
a kind of a a new
um intro theme uh they
ramped up the special effects they're
trying to look like something out of the
damn movie you know like out of The
Conjuring universe or something even
though this predates the Cadre Universe
I believe well when did the first
Conjuring movie come out 2014.
[Music]
I don't know they just got amazing you
know maybe it was early kind of edit
them a little bit more like a movie
so they've kind of gone away from the
document the documentary type format of
the first seasons but it's still good
still good I liked it that's the thing I
kind of feel like I mean there had been
paranormal Shades before obviously but I
think a haunting was sort of it wasn't
like the OG one or anything like that
but it was kind of one of the first big
like real popular ones
and I feel like the success of that led
to the 50 million other paranormal shows
that they have on now the still and so
I guess like the competition they felt
like the competition you know so like
all these other shows it's like well we
have to ramp up you know we have to amp
up the game because all these we have
all these other shows to like compete
with it but honestly I think the
original haunting shows that were just
like a documentary format were a lot
spookier spookier like I thought they
were crazy and I I really don't like the
ghost hunter type shows like where it's
just like a bunch of douches like
sitting around in a dark room did you
hear that with night vision yeah I heard
it something breathed on me I'm like
okay
that's like I can't watch starting with
Taps yeah Taps I think was the best of
them out of that bunch and that was the
first one and uh but the thing is you I
could only take so much of that
um you were always kind of like thinking
that maybe they'll catch something you
know maybe they'll actually catch
something one of these days no they
never do no the only thing that kind of
was close to something there was a
couple of them that they did with
the one they went to a lighthouse I
think it was out on an island
where they
had a camera looking up the spiral
staircase going up to the top of the
lighthouse and it looked like something
moved from one stair to the other
something small but it might have been a
bird
yeah it could have been a million others
could it might have been a damn seagull
up there sleeping and sleeping in the
lighthouse there's no way of knowing
what it was but
that looked like something and then they
were in an old
prison at night and it looks like
something moved
or went into one of the cells as they
were walking uh with night vision but
that could have been something too it
might have been an animal it might have
been a rat or something ran in there I
don't know
but uh they can't plan that over and
over again something did look like it
moved
weird those shows drive me nuts though
because
you know that they sat in this abandoned
mall or whatever the [__] for
you know eight hours or however long
they stayed in there
and you know
[__] all happened right so it's like
they have to but they have to Cobble
together something a half an hour or
hour long show so they're gonna replay a
bunch of [__] they're gonna make up a
bunch of [__] they're gonna like sit
around oh it got cold in here it's like
oh I think something touched me ooh did
you hear that it's like you know what I
mean it's like I can only watch so much
as far as the Ghost Hunter ones
the best ones of the bad ones was Ghost
brothers because ghost Brothers was just
[__] funny
black dudes on looking for ghosts and
playing kind of like playing pranks on
each other while they're looking for
ghosts and uh they just got upset in the
dark rooms by themselves they got a
camera on them I can't take this [__]
I'm getting out of here
scary dude the reason that show was good
was because the dudes themselves were
entertained they were good yeah like
even if they weren't looking for ghosts
they would still be funny to watch
because they like the interaction
between them was funny yeah um you know
just regular guys too they were right
they weren't really weren't
parapsychology and they weren't they
were they weren't taking it super
seriously which I was on board with they
were like you gonna make me sit in there
all night in that dark okay man yes you
can do it you can do it that's just [__]
you're funny yeah they're just like
[__] with you yeah the whole time
yeah there ain't no ghosts are here
[Laughter]
[__] creepy though
it's just funny that's what I mean I'm
getting out of here yeah they were just
they were just like really funny dudes
just on their own yeah I kind of feel
like the reason that a lot of Ghost
Hunter shows I don't like them is
because they take themselves like way
too seriously and they're re I mean you
know I guess they're really trying to
like prove paranormal [__] or they're
trying to make a good show or whatever
but they I don't know it's just
they take it too seriously they're not
having fun with it they're not you know
and they're just they're they're just
like every time somebody you know farts
sideways they're just like oh my gosh
it's on it you know what I mean yeah
it's just I I can't and the Bigfoot
shows are even worse like killing
Bigfoot and [__] man that is like that
has got to be I mean somebody should see
rednecks jumping up out of the ground
with shotguns in the middle of the night
did you hear that kill bigfoot this time
you just [__] stupid [__] well and
that's even dumb I'm not even out in the
middle of nowhere that's even dumber
because it's like you're out in the
middle of the woods it's like that could
literally be a million different things
there's like the woods are full of
animals
duh that's not how you find Bigfoot if
there is a Bigfoot you find Bigfoot with
a [__] thermal imaging satellite
that's how you do it it's the same way
you find a deer and [__]
you know like going out there put on
your ghillie suit and lay down in the
ditch yeah just look and wait and drink
Beer's gonna go by are animals that are
normally out there yeah that's what I'm
saying it's just like so so every time
like a raccoon like Yeah strolls by
they're just like oh my God where's that
Bigfoot yeah you'll be lucky if you see
a panther you know Panther you'll see
mountain lion you know [__] like that
bear we see Bear all the time though uh
no and and I don't think anywhere in the
continental United States is there going
to be a Bigfoot
if something like that exists to be in
Canada
by now
but I think there's a couple places in
Washington state where man's probably
never tread
I'd start looking there but the best way
to do that there's no roads or anything
you need a satellite
you know you're gonna need a satellite
yeah you can see thermal images a bunch
of dumpy Hicks sitting out in the middle
of the woods like you're not gonna find
a basement no it's not gonna be fast
what are the chances that if there was a
Bigfoot that he's gonna walk in front of
it yeah your chance to be zero you don't
want a [__] overhead look and you're
gonna be able to scroll through and
looking at thermal images go yeah okay
that's [__] elk okay yeah that's
[__] bare what the [__] is that you
know oh that's a dude okay and that's a
dude walking around looks is he [__]
that goat
you can see [__] like that well see now
that's the kind of show I would watch
when you get oh you can find that kind
of stuff you know I got that idea right
that's more interesting to me those
Choppers
I think it was in Afghanistan as
Choppers in Afghanistan were watching
some guys they were getting ready to
blow them up and one of the dudes was
out in the field to walk down in the
field and started screwing screwing the
Sheep
they got him on thermal looking at him
they're laughing the the chopper pilots
and the Gunners are [__] look at him
look at him go you gotta see him you
know you don't you ever saw that gun
camera footage used to be up yeah yeah
you should skip on YouTube yeah I think
yeah they're laughing at him
I think they blow him up eventually but
well at least he died yeah
I think they blew up later unless the
attack started they let him finish at
least that was nice well they had to
attack the compound they were just that
four sheep is like that was just
something they solved I was just right
here chewing grass and look at look at
what happened
that's not cool don't go raping animals
people
well the recording of the camera footage
they picked through and killed every guy
that was out there
eventually so I don't think he could
have got away you can't run from a
helicopter that's why that's why I was
[__] saying remember we were watching
Red Dawn
yeah and and the good guys the
Wolverines they ran from that [__]
Soviet Chopper on the back on Horseback
okay you cannot run from a helicopter on
Horseback but you know they put that in
movies all the time where people run
away from Cars yeah and I'm like how
fast can a person run yeah you know like
even the Olympic dudes can only run what
maybe yeah I don't even know what the
fastest dude alive is but it's like a
car yeah that car is going to run you
down in about two seconds take it from
being out running next infantry man we
[__] used to fight them [__] fight
[__] Apaches and cobras [__] with
Miles gear just for during training
simulations if a helicopter if attack
helicopter sees you you're dead it's
basically the Terminator and it's flies
and there you can't hide from it there's
nowhere you can run there's nothing that
you could hide in you could go if you
went into a building they'd blow that
building up you just can't you can't get
away from it if you ran down into a
[__] tunnel they'd [__] blow the
mouth of the tunnel up and collapse it
in on you and kill you you can't run
from a helicopter it sees you and then
it kills you the same way you walking
around and you're seeing ants you can
just step on them that's what they do to
you
it's a killing machine
Zach says one of my favorite paranormal
YouTubers is the foreman Brothers AKA
paranormal nightmares they're really
earthy and real and genuine good guys I
think you'd like them I should look that
up I don't watch a lot of paranormals
like I like
um like the scary stories which aren't
always paranormal a lot of them are like
true crime stories like oh I escaped a
serial killer and [__] like that which
you know or some weirdo was like living
in my attic or something but um I like a
lot of those but I don't usually watch a
lot of paranormal ones I will I watch a
lot of True Crime though that's for sure
because to me that's kind of scarier
um I think that was the last oh uh
October 8th said once when I was
homeless I was camping at one of the
pools uh old house that we skated at and
a ball was rolling around by itself I
would have run but I was too high and
tired it was scary but cool yes I wasn't
that high like not so high that that
they were seeing like [__]
[__] like that well yeah I mean the [__]
that happened at our house we weren't
High either we were just like sitting
there waiting for a movie to come on and
it was just uh sudden yeah
I had never seen anything like that
before but like I said after it happened
I was just kind of like huh
it was just kind of neat
[Laughter]
but you know all right so uh are we done
yep
oh can Knox said I had my septum pierced
in eighth grade it burned for a sec but
it happened so fast there wasn't any
pain yeah because I thought they had
like a because you know when they pierce
your ears they have that gun that just
goes kajunk
so you don't even like feel anything
so I guess I assume they have that for
your nose too not for me I ain't gonna
do it
well now well I don't yeah
like I said if I did my nose I'd
probably do it up here I don't think I'd
want to do the middle but yeah after
that
you were you were traumatized by having
to do the piercings yeah
yeah and I didn't even look because he
even said like before he was like don't
look and I was like well I wasn't gonna
but you know what I mean now later on
that night I started thinking about it
but I had Clarity of I had kind of
clarity of purpose when I was doing it
you know what I mean you can't get
squeamish you know once you start you
just gotta do it you gotta have yeah you
can't half-ass it you can't and once you
got one of them done you have to do the
other one
even though I really didn't want to I
was thinking to do it either I was
thinking about just leaving it yeah and
just being just happened I didn't really
want to do it either but now I got let's
get it done because I kept like putting
it off we sat and watched a movie and I
was like uh I'm just glad that that
Quinn was like no man their placement's
right they're straight they're deep in
there so [__] they're up against the
areola so no that's it that's a good job
that's your first one they look good
yeah yeah that's my first job because
yeah you did good yeah
even though it was it was a harrowing
the worst thing to do is if they're away
from the areola dangling you don't want
that
and then you don't want to Crooked
either some some people have done it
well yeah because that's the thing you
can't just have them like kind of
hanging out because I was kind of
worried it's like well I was like what
happens like if I have to wear a sports
bra or something like that like it's
gonna chafe and no they're uptight
against the yeah so it's like you don't
you can't even really it doesn't look
like bars it looks like two little studs
on either side of the Orioles yeah
that's what it looks like yeah because
we started out with like the smallest
yeah you don't see the bar you just see
the studs the little balls they're
pretty and you could change out the
colors and everything
yeah we'll we'll get some more jewelry
yeah
there's different versions you can get
things with dangling stuff and whatever
so you can change up some of them are
little bats
yeah you can get all kinds of fun stuff
Zach says my sister has one of those
little studs on the side of her nostril
I always thought those looked really
cute yeah me too like actually there's
um a girl at work has a little
is it a little stud or like a little
ring I can't remember and it's kind of
cute yeah
but I think that's all yeah so we we got
to the end of the episode and it's only
8 37 which is good okay because we'll
get back to watching I'm uh Series yeah
if you want and I'm super tired I can I
can probably watch a couple but I don't
know why I guess I was still thinking
about the [__]
the the [__] piercing thing but I
didn't sleep very good last night I just
kept waking up and I think another thing
too was that for some reason like Pookie
usually hangs out in the room with us
because she'll run in the bedroom it's
like oh she wants a meat stick or
something like that and she'll lay on
the bed and watch movies and stuff but I
went to the dollar store yesterday and
got her some new little toys like I got
her a little bunny and a little chick or
whatever
and
I was looking for and I couldn't find
her and then I was like
when the evening came I was like I have
not seen her like all day and I was like
looking around the house and I couldn't
find her and I was like I didn't know
where she was and I was like did she get
a locked in a closet did she get you
know run outside somehow
um you know what I mean we didn't see
her and so like all night I kept waking
up going where the [__] is Pookie and
like I kept waking up and like I'd go to
the bathroom and it's like I couldn't
see her and I was freaking out so then
like this morning when I got up to go to
work finally she was like just sitting
by the water fountain like yeah like
nothing happened and I was like where
the [__] have you been she hides and I
don't she must have some hiding places I
don't know about yeah because I mean
I've found most of her hiding places
yeah but she's pretty smart and she gets
it but I'm always worried that she's
like I said that she's gonna
you know slip out the door while we're
not looking or
um or she's gonna get locked in a closet
because she likes to run in the closet
for some reason
you know she wants to get clothes in the
closet yeah I think she does she wants
to get closed in there yeah she thinks
that I don't know why but she thinks
it's funny she'll try to sneak around if
you open the bedroom closet she tries to
like very casually like walk behind you
like that like La La Land not even
looking at the closet yeah and then she
goes and hides in there and she'll curl
up like way in the far corner like you
can't see me you can't see me she wants
you to lock her in the closet yeah she
wants to get trapped in there I'm not
really sure why she's super weird but I
don't want her to get trapped in there
because then in the middle of the night
she'll want out and she'll start yelling
and like you know she's gotta go use the
litter box she'll just take it that's
what I mean her she'll just like poop in
your shoes or something like that and
nobody wants that so you know you can't
let her stay in there but she for some
reason she really wants to but I think
that's why I kept waking up because I
didn't know where she was but I found
her all right so that'll do it for
today's super thanks should be activated
so you guys today is haunting and nipple
piercing show yeah that's what we're
gonna call it uh so yeah taking the day
off tomorrow but
or well at least from the show but then
Wednesday we're gonna do our main show
which is gonna be about the Boca Town
Center murders which is something I
didn't really know anything about yeah
it happened in 2007. It Happened down in
uh South Florida okay and there was a
lot of yeah and there was it was kind of
like a high-end mall and there was like
all these murders like in the parking
lot okay but yeah so that's what we're
gonna do the show about on Wednesday
because that's what won the polls so you
know if you want to get in on the polls
you can either go over and join patreon
or you can become a YouTube member
because I also post the polls everywhere
on the for YouTube members as well so
you can vote over here but uh yeah
that's what one so that's we're gonna be
talking about on Wednesday night so
hopefully you guys can drop by for that
so uh yeah thanks for hanging out with
us this evening and we will see you
again on Wednesday night